carl there
there was um microphones caught g you
and jimmy having a little conversation
at the end of the game do you i mean
was that were your emotions running high
at that point what was kind of going
through your head as that game came to
an end there
man they grown man dawg they be just
talking
having a regular conversation if you ask
me i mean
if this if it's a if y'all come to see
us compete it's
it's no competition if we're not talking
[ __ ] to each other you know what i'm
saying so
if whatever y'all can take that with a
grain of salt like i said they've grown
as
me and they having a conversation it's
regular regular conversation
well that's why we asked the question
anne just to try and get the get your
guys's view on it right
regular conversation that's all it was
nothing else nothing more
chase go ahead hey and so who was
getting emotional in the third quarter
um
that's about it uh yeah you know but
like i said we'll take the blame you
know
it happened uh we put ourselves in that
uh in that whole you know
school though
[Music]
[Applause]
had adebayo going to the line where he's
one of two tonight miami 16 of 23.
jimmy butler and karl anthony towns are
really going at it and they're going to
call double technicals on jimmy
yeah you could you picked up some of
that on the mic but
it's i'll let people listen for
themselves and
not really going to comment much on that
we all know there's history
[Applause]
pam hits the first to 14 for him
you tonight see towns and butler kind of
drawn at each other here